[MUSIC PLAYING]
So when I'm thinking
through a project like this,
I kind of want to
map out in my head
or on a piece of paper
sort of what I want to do
and where I want things to go.
So in this case,
we have this need
to adopt a persona every
day with a secret codename.
And so we can use pins for
that kind of as the backbone
for this because we might
end up deciding that we want,
for one, a Shiny app
that we can log into
and we can see what our
codename is for the day.
We might want a daily email that
tells us what our codename is
delivered to our box.
Or we could even go so far
as, let's make a Slack bot
that runs, and it sends
me a Slack message
and tells me what my name
is, these kinds of things.
So we might have need for
this information of what
our daily generated codename
is going to be delivered
in multiple ways.
And so that's why I think using
a pin for this information
of what's my real name and
what's my codename going to be.
So we're going to start off and
we're going to have this pin.
We're going to
have our username,
you have to forgive my
handwriting, and our codename.
And so this is just
going to be data.
What's it going to be?
So we're going to take
this, you'll love this,
we're just going to stick
this thing on a pin.
Use this here.
How are we going to
get this information?
We want this to be
updated on a daily basis.
And so one of the best
ways that we can do this,
let's make a little script, and
this is going to be generate,
that's what that
says, generate, pin.
This is going to be a
R Markdown document,
and we're just going to
schedule this little puppy.
We'll publish this
on the Connect.
We'll schedule it
so every single day,
my R Markdown document is
going to take my list of users,
take a list of
generated codenames,
smoosh them together,
and stick it into a pin.
So we'll do that, stick this
up here, and then from this
we have other things
that we can do.
We can make a Shiny app.
Here's your Shiny app, and
you can make this Shiny,
stick this here.
You could do other things.
You could have a Slack bot.
You could have an
email, and that email,
we would generate that
with an R Markdown document
in blastula, for example.
Have Connect send that on
our behalf via R Markdown.
The Slack bot as well, we could
generate that with a script,
put that up in R Markdown.
So all of these things
are using our pin.
So these are all
the little elements
that we're going
to put into place.
You might go back
to the beginning
and say, well, OK, how are we
going to get our usernames?
And where are we going
to pull this from?
It just so happens I have
another pin just sitting around
that does have all of
the usernames for folks
that are on our Connect server.
So I've already
got this as a pin.
So what a fun project.
We're actually going to
start with data that's pinned
and bring it into an R
Markdown, create another pin,
and then use it for
downstream assets.
Sound fun?
All right, so let's get cooking.
We'll start with this
R Markdown document.
That's going to be
our pin generator.
So we need to pull
in our usernames.
So generate_pins.
So you're only doing one pin.
All right, clean all
of this stuff up.
And so what do we want to do?
First, we need to get
some libraries in.
We need pins.
We're going to need dplyr.
I need to spell it correctly.
My favorite little package
for generating codenames,
one little one called IDs.
OK, so this should
be all that we need.
First, we're going to
go grab the user data
information that we have.
So we're going to use
pins to find a board,
board_rsconnect, and run that.
So yep, we've got
our board defined,
and let's get our users.
Send board pin read into
my board and it is--
what was it?
User?
Users?
User.
I think it's user.
Let's try it.
Hey, it seemed to work.
OK, awesome.
We've got user
information, 166 users.
Cool.
All right, so we can take this.
We don't need any
of this other stuff.
What I want to do is just get
username and assign a codename.
And my ultimate goal
for this Shiny app
is I want the user to log
in, pull up the Shiny app,
and I want the Shiny app
to know who that user is
and then tell them
their codename.
So we're going to
use for that app,
just kind of charting
the course here,
we're going to use this ability
to do session$user on the app
so that we can
distinguish who is who.
And now let's make
up some codenames.
So let's make a table
here, codenames.
Let's take users, and we
just want the username,
and we want to mutate
plus the codename equals--
let's see, I got
to go by memory.
Yeah, let's play around a
minute with this IDs function.
IDs, adjective animal, OK.
Adjective_animal, n equals 1.
Let's just for kicks,
let's spit out five.
One adjective, in
that case, and, well,
let's just see what we get.
Ha ha ha, cool.
Oh, no, I don't
like some of those,
but, all right, run
this a couple of times,
and we've got some good stuff.
OK, so this is
what we want to do.
We want to use adjective animal.
Codename equals
adjective_animal,
and let's see.
Some of these can be
a little bit wild.
So let's put-- I
remember from other--
playing with this package.
It gets a little--
some of the names get to
be a little bit excessive
if you don't put a
maximum length on it.
So let's see what we get.
That's not good.
Everybody's a frugal_pitbull.
Oh, let's do this, n equals
number of rows and users.
Is that going to get me
so I have unique names?
Yes.
Doughty_nyala, that's awesome.
Concave_flamingo, yeah.
All right, now we are cooking.
Every time we run this, it's
going to cook up new names.
So I want to make it
unique for every day.
So let's set the seed, and does
this work as numeric sys date?
All right, set the
seed codenames.
Do we get the same?
I didn't set the seed twice.
Lazy_newt, perfect.
OK, we have stable codenames.
And now all we need to do,
I'm not talking to my code
very well, create codename.
This is obvious, table,
and now we need to pin it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So we're going to take our
board, add that into pin
write, and we're going
to put codenames to it.
I'm going to publish
this as well.
So we can put it on a schedule.
So let's publish this little--
put that there.
We're going to publish this.
Here we go.
We are deployed.
All right, so we've
got our pin generator.
We're writing the pins now.
Let's schedule this.
Otherwise, we're going to
end up with the same codename
every day.
So let's run this and,
yeah, we should probably
run this at just a little
after midnight every day.
That sounds good.
So now this is going to run.
It's going to run
on a daily basis.
So here's our graphic
of where we are.
It's going to run and every
day update this pin for us.
So say we wanted to make
the Shiny app that's
going to include name.
It's going to tell us every
day what our codename is.
I am not the world's most
elegant Shiny developer,
but I will get by this session.
Here we go.
Yes.
We love a good clean slate.
OK, so for our Shiny app,
we're going to need Shiny.
Let's see, are we going
to need anything else?
Of course, we're
going to need pins.
Again, can't spell, pins.
And then, all right, so
what do we want this to do?
First, we're going to want to
bring in our codename table.
So we're going to
do that, board.
This is going to
look familiar, right?
Board equals rsconnect, and
codenames equals pin_read board
and then what we call it.
What do we call it?
Do we call it codenames?
I think so.
All right, cross your fingers.
Ha ha, look at that, codenames.
There we are, you Lazy_newt.
OK, so where were we?
Need to bring it all in and
have a nice little greeting.
So on our main panel,
let's give textOutput,
and this will just
be our greeting.
All right, and then
what is our greeting?
It is going to be something
along the lines of--
probably do renderText.
And then let's do like a
paste hello secret agent.
And then we need to
put in the username,
however we determine it to be.
All right, we need
to figure out what
our username is going to be.
So how do we know the username?
So two things.
We are going to
know the username
based on who is logged in.
So the username is going to be
user_name equals session$user.
However, I want to be
able to test this locally.
So I'm going to do a little
environment swaparoo.
All right, so we're
going to set our default,
and we're just
developing locally.
We're going to say
that our default is me.
And then when you're
using the session$user,
that can be identified with
the environment variable
for our config.
So let's do get environment
variable, R_CONFIG_ACTIVE.
So if the active
configuration is rsconnect,
is this making sense?
R_CONFIG_ACTIVE is rsconnect.
User_name is session$user.
Otherwise, it's me.
All right, output
greeting, hello.
Right, and now we also
need to figure out what
our codename is going to be.
So we say hello to
ourselves, and then we say,
Today, you shall be known as.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There we go.
And then we will put in
textOutput, codename.
Now we have to define what
the codename is going to be.
So codename equals renderText.
User_ codename, let's call it.
We have to define what that is.
So let's stick that up
here, user_codename.
So we've got the pin.
We've got the pin with our
username and our codename.
So we're just going to take
our codenames table, filter it.
Username equals user_name,
and then we'll just pull.
So for kicks, so we
say username is this.
We've got our codenames.
What do we end up with?
Codenames.
Where did we fill out?
Exposable_tuna?
Oh!
Codname!
Those cods, OK.
So it is.
Let's go with cod.
Makes it even more
secretive and suspicious.
Let's see, is that
going to bite us
anywhere else, those feisty cod?
I think we should
be in good shape.
OK, so let's test this out,
see if this runs locally.
Codname, oh my gosh.
Ha ha ha, fabulous.
Let's publish this puppy.
Let's go.
Codenames generator.
Let's call it secret
codenames generator.
No!
Oh, can't find pull.
Library dplyr to the rescue.
All right, try that again.
Exposable_tuna!
So from here, I guess
we could leave it
an exercise to the reader to
build out more assets to round
out our secret agent personas.